was talking to the accountant who's that
you won't need to be vot registered like
that's coming down the line and when she
looked for the videos like okay you
probably will since we started about
three four months ago the companies
turned over 35k welcome to the big boy
club you came down you made calls you
got no no no but you've just got to keep
going until you get here that one bright
and deal how much does it make profit 3K
a month
your first deal is always your hardest
deal because once you've been your first
deal confidence goes Sky High it's very
hard to build up your reputation that's
so easy to lose here why would they pay
300 pounds a night to stay at your place
when they could just stay at a hotel
Alfie and Jess thank you for coming on
Windows on a Wednesday and
congratulations on becoming financially
free in the last few months thank you
you guys have been smashing it out the
park so what's been your strategy then
and what's your background yeah I know
you both were working for the NHS yeah
so what what happened how did you go
from working as NHS workers to now
full-time in property so we came to your
crash course probably about a year
before we ever done anything
um both working in the NHS nine to five
came to the crash course didn't sign up
to anything everyone was running to the
back of the room we were sort of a bit
skeptical it's a bit too much money we
can do it on our own yeah didn't do
anything obviously and went away for
about a year was on holiday in Turkey on
our way back and now if we put on ibby
and hustlins winners on a Wednesday
video
um and when I woke up like obviously all
days and I was like we need to do this
I'm going to sell my car like yeah we
need to like sign up to the academy came
home obviously contacted ibby with about
15 minutes if you had called us and
obviously told a surprise etc etc we
were like oh we I don't know how we're
going to fund it Alfie is obviously a
personal trainer and was down the gym at
the time and I just sort of took it up
on my I couldn't get hold of him I took
it upon myself to just try and get a
bank loan to pay for it oh wow
um and I said to AVR I'll call you back
in like a couple of days like we'll try
and sort out the finances I must have
called him back in about 20 minutes and
was like I've got it I've sorted it I
sign up like so you just got like a loan
yeah like it was in the bank and then
went from there we didn't go for our
first live training until January so we
signed up end of October and we're just
kind of going through the online
training but very slowly like we
underestimated what we needed to do and
how much content there is yeah like we
would watch like two or three videos a
night
yeah that's enough yeah turn it off next
day go on there free videos yeah and
it's kind of just going like that and
then when it's to the live training you
was on stage calling people like we was
just sitting it up we haven't done
nothing yeah yeah and from that then we
stepped it up didn't we I think that's
when you realize as well when you when
you're around other people and you're in
the right environment and you can see
people like it be myself who are
smashing the phones out and you think
man this is the intensity is high you
really just sort of plodge your way to
success I don't think especially when
you're young and you've got a job you
need to put the work in and you need to
do what most people are not prepared to
do so that then down the line you can
live in it like you guys are now you
know you're financially free you're
you're you both quit your job so
congratulations yes thank you and it's
funny as well because I was chatting
with Emmy just yesterday because I saw
something flashed up on my Facebook
um I think it was like four years ago
and it was a picture of ibby at his
first crash course saying one day you'll
see me on winners on a Wednesday it's
just crazy how he ended up becoming
successful coming on Windows Wednesday
then he's nudging you that's all awesome
so what did your friends and family
think when you told them you just drop
thousands of pounds on mentoring and
education to do property as NHS workers
you've got a loan to do it we didn't
actually tell them when we come to the
training we said oh we we've got to go
to Heathrow we're doing some training it
was a little bit of money we said it's
about a thousand pound they were
supportive but I think because we was
young it was more like they was just a
bit skeptical like they rooted for us
but at the same time obviously had their
doubts like most people but the thing is
now you're you're making like how much a
month profit so last month we profited
12K
so you made the full investment back in
in a month yeah you know what I mean and
I know you've been doing consistently
yeah well how much have you done in the
last few months
um so since we started about three four
months ago the company's turned over 35k
that's awesome yeah wow yeah we was
talking to the accountant which was that
you won't need to be vat registered like
that's coming down the line and then
when she looked through the video she
was like okay
a couple months yeah we'll be there I
need to be done what is it 85 yeah so
once you turn them over 85 000 then vat
registered and yeah suddenly you've got
to up your prices exactly how's that
going to affect your business do you
think what do you think will happen when
you suddenly have to add 20 of that on
everything I think we're just gonna have
to play around with the prices a little
bit
um obviously make sure we're still
getting the profit that we want but
still being competitive obviously it
does make your business a bit more
credible I think when you're ready to
registered so you've been running for a
while etc etc
on everything yeah exactly so when
you're buying because it pretty much
every company is that ready yeah if you
stay at a hotel you're paying that yeah
I might not know you're paying that but
you're paying that but when you're a vet
registered company you then claiming
that back to which normal people can't
do it yeah of course and I I found
certainly I know you do a bit a bit of
deal seven as well but I found as a deal
seller when I became that registered and
suddenly sat 20 on it didn't actually
affect anything no it's all in your head
you're thinking like oh everyone's
paying me 3 000 pounds for a deal but
three thousand six hundred well they're
still pay me but
people people will yeah that's just the
figure yeah it's just that's just what
happens somebody said probably a lot of
people in Brighton are in the same boat
we just don't realize yeah yeah so it's
like everyone's there welcome to the big
boy club yeah
very soon anyway very soon so what
happened then so you've got a low now
enrolled into the academy you've got the
mentorship we're plotting through the
courses until you came in person and
then it's like okay what happened then
what happened at that program did you
were you making calls how's it going
yeah we was making calls like the
exercises go away cool tent but even in
them exercises you didn't get any
um luck well not luck but we didn't get
any progress yeah and then you'd come
back in the room you sort of hear people
we got a deal so even then it's quite
disheartening but it's like the vibe
will come and then obviously we've done
all the training and then that's when it
was like we started calling people and
then we got our first one yeah where was
it where was your first deal right tell
me about how you got it and go through
it go through so this one was on open
rent and it was just a message obviously
you've got to be quite careful with what
you say in the messages
um but yeah that was fire so we've got
the view in went and see the viewing
perfect but it took about two months to
actually get the deal signed we needed a
guarantor which the the solicit a heater
list so I was being quite harsh well I'd
say
um but yeah we've got the guarantor and
then that was it when it which didn't
come easy tell me about that so and also
sorry but tell me what a guarantor is
and why did you need one so he didn't
just need a normal guarantor of you know
earn enough money he wanted a home owner
guarantor so the rent we're paying on
that is a three-bedroom house like right
on the seafront in Brighton so the rent
is quite higher and he wanted a
homeowner guarantor specifically so
there's not that many people around us
who we knew we could ask we'd asked a
couple family members who were just like
you know what no it's too risky yeah
that that took a while we changed
guarantors I think about three times but
in the end Alpha sister yeah and her
fiance pulled through and respect yeah
what's your sister's name Siobhan shout
out to Siobhan yeah big shout out and I
said that to your member when we were
trying to get the ACP a few weeks back
and I was saying like a massive shout
out you got to remember the people that
helped you that's true you know it's you
it's true we was ready to walk away from
that deal because we thought we don't
know how we're gonna get it we didn't
know how he was going to get the
homeowner coming tour and then we was
really nervous to ask her as well wasn't
we and then she was just like yeah of
course I'll do it like go for it what'd
you need would you need yeah and that's
the thing as well like when I first got
my first property I was 17 and my mom's
husband my stepdad Tim he was a
guarantor to me and it's like this
business is if you can't get a deal you
failed the reference check you need a
homeowner guarantor sometimes people
will just say oh I can't do it yeah oh
I've got bad credit oh I've got no
credit I'm too young or my job doesn't
earn enough I'm not a homeowner I can't
do it whereas in business and as an
entrepreneur you've got to say well how
can I yeah who can help me and there's
always someone that can help you it's
about finding that person asking in the
right way and even if you ask someone
you could have said oh we asked our
parents to ask this and they said no
therefore what are we going to do we're
just gonna have to stay at the NHS we
can't do it what a brilliant excuse and
people are full of excuses but what you
guys did was you kept asking until
somebody said yes yeah and I think it's
the same of interest you came down you
made calls you got no no no but you've
just got to keep going until you get a
yes yeah for sure and they do come like
you always find that landlord who is
tired like this particular one was
running it as an Airbnb himself he's a
multiple business owner like he's not
shy of money but he lives in Brighton
and was doing all the cleaning himself
wow like he's running loads of
businesses and was cleaning that Airbnb
himself why did he not get I just don't
think the knowledge yeah he didn't know
so he needs to get a loan out and come
do the academy as well
yeah she literally said sorry he
literally said like I just want my rent
and then be done with it not to be rude
and was like perfect like that's what
we're here for yeah yeah and since then
we've not even I think we've messaged
him two or three times in four five
months knowledge and network yeah two
most important things definitely so that
property then so you got it you got you
got it through how much do you have to
pay the the landlord so we're paying the
landlord 2 400 Ren yeah and then our
bills are about 350 on top so that
sounds like a full-time salary yeah we
that was basically what we was earning
so you committed to basically put down
your entire salary on a property and
that's another interesting thing that
psychologically how did you have the
confidence to take that huge step
because that might not worked so we
didn't actually have the money to do it
um that again was another loan from the
bank
God bless the bank God bless the bank
yeah how much does it cost how much you
have to put down we put down 10 000 into
that deal
um we probably did go a bit over budget
with the Furnishing and stuff like that
it was our first one we just we wasn't
nice on the beach yes yeah yeah what was
it an apartment uh it's a Mason at three
floors it's got a nice outdoor Terrace
it's like quite Victorian it's really
nice but before we had that one we was
obviously booking viewings everywhere
and we would have really took anything
but this one what we got it was it's
like a gold mine it's perfect it's got
the outdoor Terrace which is hard in
Brighton because most of them are like
Studios and stuff what are your
repayments or what's the interest you
having to pay on the bank loan that you
got for the property in Brighton I think
it's about six percent or something okay
um the only money we really had to pay
out of our own pocket was that very
first loan we got for the academy for
like six months and we hadn't got
anything in property that was yeah the
only money was paying out of our own
pocket since then we've not touched a
penny of our own so that one writing
deal how much does it make profit I do
3K a month three thousand average profit
yeah that is insane I bet your your
sister loves going inside
so you put down 10 grand yeah which you
got as a loan yeah but now you're making
three grand a month how long do you
reckon you'll have that for have you got
an agreement with the four years four
years that's like probably about 135
Grand yeah that's really good yeah so is
that when you quit your job so no I
actually quit my job on the first live
course in January
we was two days in and we were saying an
Airbnb and I just came home and I said I
can't go back what did you quit it was
just the environment knowing how
negative the office environment was
everyone's stuck in the nine to five
constantly working overtime like just
being expected to do it and I just knew
if I went back to my desk that my brain
would leave the property staff yeah and
I wouldn't put my all into it would
invest it into our education and I just
knew I couldn't go back Alfie was
working self-employed as a PT at this
point so we were still covered like
we're still living at home our living
expenses are really low
um so we could afford to take that risk
and yeah I mean it's a really tough one
people ask me all the time
should I leave my job and do properties
that my answer usually is no yeah
because normally I'll say go and get you
at least get one or two deals to prove
that you can do it but sometimes people
I just like have to I just have to quit
yeah and I guess if you've not got
massive responsibilities no you know how
old are you guys 23 23 yeah yeah no kids
or mortgages or anything like that so it
kind of makes sense and it was it's even
like I had a nice expensive car what I
was paying for and then when it was like
we see your bees and hustlings winners
on a Wednesday it was like no literally
come back off that holiday within the
first week I sold it to We Buy Any Car
except for that's a liability yeah
minimal get rid of all everything we
have and then we can just mainly focus
on finding the deals where are your
deals have you all your properties in
Brighton yeah you've just you've just
gone hard on Brighton yeah all our deals
are in Brighton and the ones that we've
like deal sourced onto people in the
Academy have all been in Brighton as
well see we've got the proof that we're
doing it ourselves there so we know the
area so yeah it's good told me about how
do you work out whether to keep a deal
for yourself or to sell it when we do
this and negotiating between me and you
isn't it like yeah the last one we sold
I really wanted to keep it it was lovely
it was suggested because she was kind of
like we've got to like let's try and
build the part so it's not really should
we take it because it's like don't suit
us it's like can we take it have we got
the money too yeah and I think where
we've got our two now we sort of know
the guests who are coming in know what
they want the last deal that we sold was
quite like a luxury yeah like Penthouse
rooftop blah blah the guests don't
really need that so the extra little bit
that you might get on a nightly rate the
demand probably won't match here like
they just they need something basic who
are you guests then so if you're getting
three grand profit you must be getting a
turnover of what like six grand five
eight I think 5 800 yeah so you're
charging on average per night about what
is that like a couple hundred pounds or
so yeah we're getting about 309 300
pounds a night yes why would they pay
300 pounds a night to stay at your place
when they could just stay at a hotel I
think with a hotel room obviously you're
limited to two maybe four people in a
hotel room yeah no kitchen no nice
Terrace right nothing kind of like your
own space when you go into ours it's a
three-bedroom property so automatically
you can already sleep bigger groups or a
family yeah family can all be in the
same space yeah I think we're actually
cheaper than the hotels you probably are
yeah it's funny because when I go before
I had kids
um I didn't stay in
airbnb's as much or like all like home
from home type stuff because I believe
just me and Amanda so we just go and
stay at hotels but now we've got kids
it's different story because it's like
we can't go and stay at a hotel with our
three kids yeah because what we're gonna
put one massive family room yeah and
then if the kids just with us all night
we can't book two rooms we can't let the
kids go and stay in another room like
what do we get so the answer is we have
to find a property like yours where
you've got like two three bedrooms
you've got a little kitchen and also
people tend to stay there longer as well
don't they I Hotel you might be there
one or two nights but what we've done as
well like we said 300 pounds a night but
we've got guests in there now who have
stayed for six weeks but then the
nightly rate is around 180 pound so
which is really competitive with the
hotels but obviously you get so much
more with an Airbnb yeah so it's cheaper
for them obviously we're we're not
losing money because now they're it's
100 occupancy and you you've not got to
be getting cleaners in and out no your
overheads are less yeah I mean you guys
are the perfect example of when people
say we've got no money I we've you know
not got like great credit behind us
you've obviously got some credit because
you're able to get a loan we'll work
full time really busy but we want to get
into property and you guys have kind of
cracked the code so to speak yeah with
the strategy that you've got how did you
choose Brighton as an area because I
know you don't live in Bryan so what
made you choose Brian it was like one of
your training courses we booked a
mentoring call we didn't have anything
and it was with
um hustling and we were just sort of
going through like what strategy we
wanted to do because we was unsure and
we started talking about essay and we
was like yeah we could do sa and
hustling she said Brighton works very
well and it sort of just stuck with us
like it was looking at other areas but
she said Brighton that that will work
very well so then saying that is that we
went home and then obviously when we
were on open rent we'd search Brighton
straight away Gumtree with search
Brighton and then just keep sending them
messages calling people and then
eventually we got the first one how long
did it take between getting your first
property getting the keys to getting you
second deal how long was the it was a
couple of weeks yeah literally a couple
of weeks I think once you've got one
behind you it is easier to have the
proof to say you know we've got one
already in the area I think it's
confidence as well yeah which changes
like your confidence on the phone when
you have nothing like me personally it's
like you're a bit like oh you're hoping
but then once I've got one it's like I'm
in the game now yeah and it just changes
yeah sometimes people get like a
imposter syndrome a little bit yeah yeah
when they're when you've got nothing and
you've never done any deals and you're
ringing up saying what we can offer you
is this this this and there's a little
voice in your head saying can you though
yeah can you you know you've never done
this you know and sometimes people told
me they even feel like a little bit of a
fraud because it's just like oh I'm
acting like I know what I'm talking
about but really I don't and yeah you
know I think that's why I always say
your first deal is always your hardest
deal because once you've done your first
deal you that confidence goes Sky High
and you guys were fortunate that your
first deal was a banger yeah um how much
profit you making on your second deal
free Crown what yeah but this one we've
done a JV partner with right someone on
the academy so we didn't actually use
none of our own money with this one it
was around the same 10 000 pounds of
lump in because it probably did need a
complete refurb so our JV Partners put
in all their money and then we're not
taking No profit until they get their
10K back yeah
um and then the first month we Prof the
profit was 3K that goes all to them and
then once they're all squared up then
it'll be 50 50 from there nice and what
if you've got what you're working on at
the moment what was your latest project
so bright and obviously we just still
actively trying to sell deals in
Brighton um but we're coming more to
where we live um to try and do some brr
deals yeah so now we're studying there
around our area kinds of years we've got
two viewings today nice um later today
we've taken the Builder there to get a
build quote and then yeah see from there
again like it sounds so simple you know
oh we're going to do property and we
just sell a deal and you make it look
simple we were at a training program a
couple weeks ago and you just stood up
just lesson was like oh we just made
three grounds you know from a deal that
you just literally I don't know how do
you sell deals where where are you
finding your investors what are you
saying to them how does it work I think
the network within the academy has
really really helped us will be the
first to say we probably haven't done as
much to go out and find our own
investors as we should have but we
haven't needed to yeah all the all the
deals that we have sold people within
the Academy have been the first ones to
message anyways and I think they know
how it works they're not afraid of
paying you that sourcing fee they trust
you yeah they know you've learned the
same as them
you're protected talk to me a little bit
about if a deal goes wrong mediation
redress how does it work obviously we've
got the Pim service with you with the
ndi and stuff like that if there's ever
any kind of conflict
um we can come straight to pims and ask
them to kind of mediate and yeah and it
means it means that from an Investor's
perspective if they're on the academy
and you're saying well I want three
grand
sometimes investors feel a little bit
reluctant to pay up front yeah because
they're thinking if I pay you and then
the deal falls through or the deal's
crap
and then you don't give them money back
I have a problem but then as a deal
Source you're thinking but if you don't
pay me up front and I give you the deal
and you go and secure it but then you
don't pay me yeah then if so it's a bit
of a there's a bit of a trust issue yeah
with deal sources and investors
sometimes about what comes first how
does it work I know within the academy
we have pims property investors
mediation service which says look if you
pay and then you don't deliver then
you're gonna have to give the money back
otherwise you'll be struck off but then
an investor if you ask for a refund but
then try and cut go direct to dental if
there's any problems or if anyone's
acting unethically in any way then
there's a there's a cover an umbrella of
covering and protection which covers
both parties which I think is important
for deal sellers so how is it worth them
so you find a deal let's say you go out
and find a banging BR deal at what point
do you get the deal how far do you go
before you then sell it it's obviously
before we'd go to the viewing we'd have
spoke to the estate agent and sort of
let them know and once we've run our
numbers before we've gone and then if
we've got a viewing books we kind of put
feelers out there so what does that look
like what would you do you drop a
message on the WhatsApp group yeah just
simple message a brr in Medway come in
we've got a viewing today and then you
might have a few messages and I've got
an investor
um ready so then it's like you know you
go in there with someone in mind rather
than going and doing all the work
getting the deal signed so this is ready
and then putting it in the chat and then
there's nothing yeah you've probably
heard me say before it's like baking a
cake you you know you want all the right
ingredients but also the right
measurements yeah because if you put too
much flour in the Cake's going to be dry
if you put too much sugar it'll be too
sweet and in the same way when people
say what comes first the investor or the
deal it's kind of like well you need to
just time it gently gently gently gently
gently gently bang yeah and it's it's a
skill it's an art of doing that and I
think it's the same with estate agents
as well obviously you want to build a
good relationship with them and keep
them on side so if you suddenly put an
offer in on a property and you've got no
one who wants to buy it then you're
going to annoy that oh it's very hard to
build up your reputation that's so easy
to lose it 100 so brr's coming up how do
you know if a br is good it's all about
working backwards working out what the
new value of the property could be once
it's all done up and stuff like that and
then working backwards on okay how much
needs to be spent in total for this to
be a banging deal
um and I think that's the art of the
offering without offering yeah I'm
calling an estate agent you've been
trained well yeah
yeah getting that feeler of you know the
vendor situation a lot of the time it's
obviously the estate agent so you're
going through a middleman but finding
out their situation what they want and
then figuring out whether there is that
scope for making a quite a lower offer
to get a below market value deal and
making it really profitable BR deal do
you think it's crazy how hard people
work for 2 000 pounds a month yeah
literally living proof of that like you
we would work overtime that you're not
paid for you just expect to do and it's
like you're not paid any extra for it
you're just working for someone I know
and then you just uh one of our programs
just I just made three grand yeah and
people will work a whole month for that
yeah yeah that's why I just couldn't go
back and it was just crazy it's like our
first deal three grand a month profit
yeah it took a lot of time but now
that's up and running that's more than
what we earned together wasn't it yeah
or individually I think people are
forced to have to be a bit more
entrepreneurial though because the cost
of living crisis I mean BBC announced a
couple weeks ago that the average rent
now in England not London England is 950
pounds yeah I think um Sadiq Khan has
put a prediction out that the average
rent in London is going to go up to two
and a half Grand yeah
two and a half grand for rent then
you've got your bills on top and bills
are tripling in price gas electric all
your energy counts tax so to live in
London is gonna you're talking three
four grand assuming that you don't drive
assuming that you don't celebrate
birthdays and Christmas assuming that
you don't want a holiday so if it's
going to cost you four grand to live in
London but the average salary is three
grand or less and then you've got to pay
your tax you pay aye National Insurance
what the heck is going on people can't
do that I've had three people are
realizing now people are coming to me
now where they've watched women's on a
Wednesday three years ago and we're like
really but now they're like I'm ready
yeah what do you think what do you think
about that you are right like that the
rents are going up and everyone the your
wages aren't so it's like there's a big
struggle so it's like now people are
looking for that side hustle and I think
your content on YouTube is like for me I
understood you very easily so it was
like from that it's like you're drawn in
um and then we did obviously we did go
to the crash course but even then it was
like we didn't have the fire to go yeah
let's start and then like you said like
we waited a whole year and then we'll
see the another winners of the
Wednesdays like we've got to stop
wasting our time because it'd be that
could we could have been ibby and
hustling if we started last year yeah I
think changing your mindset is the
biggest thing when we first came to that
crash course our mindset was still
in the right of a nine to five you work
you retire et cetera Etc whereas now our
mindset's like our life's completely
changed I'm wondering how far they can
push it like how long a wage is going to
stay at 25 30 around a year what
everything else is going up so high I
mean yeah it's it's getting a joke yeah
it's unsustainable it is and you're
working a good job you're working for a
hospital NHS very respectable job but
it's like it just doesn't cut it when
you're not in London especially no I
remember when I was working as an estate
agent when I was 20 years old I worked
for best at weaves Countrywide and I was
working so hard
and I was thinking if I worked this hard
on my own business my basic salary was
11 Grand a year and then I was getting
25 pound commission every time I sold a
house I sent a couple houses a week and
my boss sat me down one day and he goes
if you work really hard
you know for the next sort of five ten
years you might be able to make 30 grand
and I'm thinking okay and I'm seeing
people in like senior management
positions that are work that are bosses
they are negotiation Pros they're on 40
Grand I remember thinking if I worked
this hard on my deal sourcing business
can you imagine so you're making like
910 Grand profit but that's not even
it's not even that impressive in this
industry the scpp a couple weeks ago
there was people doing a lot more than
that yeah and even it's just the start
yeah we got the message to say come on
to winners on a Wednesday we was like
are we ready yeah yeah Are We There Yet
yeah well you guys done really well what
would you say has been the biggest
challenge the biggest struggle
throughout the whole process persevering
and pushing on when we was getting
nothing yeah like obviously we had a lot
of pressure where I'd quit my job six
months of getting nothing and not having
your normal income come in yeah you know
it took a tile we probably did get down
quite a few times and could have quit or
whatever but
pushing on and and keeping you know
believing that it's gonna come it's
worth it in the end I think a lot of
people would just quit and would go back
so Network knowledge but then
perseverance definitely perseverance the
biggest thing even now like you could
get a deal you sell a deal that's fine
and the next day you're back online you
for a week straight you might be hearing
nose nose nose again so it's then you
just kind of just got to take it in like
you say you're 100 knows away from me
yes and I kind of just remember that in
my head because then they say no I'm
like thank you and the next one and I
think when you're like that it's fine
that deal will come whereas some people
they call free estate agents which might
take three minutes here three knows and
they're like nice done yeah you've only
worked three minutes do you reckon
everybody can be successful and be an
entrepreneur or do you think that it's
just certain people that are just born
that way like I think yes they can but
it's changing their mindset first like
coming to your training on them training
days the four day courses your mindset
does change
um like you go from it's it completely
changes didn't it let you go home and
like I'm telling my dad these things and
he's looking at me like you're right
like yeah yeah and it is I think so
anyone could be successful but I think
you need the right training and the
right Network around you yeah how much
time do you have to spend managing your
um like rent to rent properties now with
that guest is just left after a month
where you haven't had to do really
anything for the whole month maybe a
message to the cleaner to say can you go
in at Monday 11 o'clock she says fine
that's it I probably don't spend any
more than an hour a week that's on two
as well yeah and that's why it's so
important to I you know there's the
saying build your house on the rock
because the last guy that was running in
the service accommodation property all
his procedures and his business was
built on the sand yeah he didn't have
systems he didn't have procedures he
didn't have it everything wasn't
automated probably didn't have a good
power team in the area he was doing
everything himself but you can't scale
that way no then you're just gonna jump
out the frying pan Into the Fire yeah
leave your job and then you just did
another job yeah but property needs to
be something that you can scale and you
can systemize and build which is really
good that you've done that what tips
would you give in systemizing your
service accommodation business education
yeah you need to get education like with
the deal we've got at prestonville where
the JV Partners put their money in
there's a shop down on the corner like a
corner shop and we was coming in there
when we was doing the refurb getting
drinks so I started chatting to him
letting him know what we was doing took
his number down because I thought if
there's any trouble he's on that road he
can contact me he actually run me
randomly at the blue the other day so
I've got a studio in Brighton I've took
it on and I was like oh great whatever
and he was talking to me he said I'm not
really having any bookings though and it
was like he had a studio and he's trying
to rent it for 180 pounds a night it was
that I said mate your competition
they're renting for 90 to 110 pounds
yeah why would they book yours so I was
on the phone for about an hour with him
he's like he said thank you so much and
he literally changed it and I think
within two days he's got like three
weeks worth of bookings yeah just by
changing the numbers the pricing is
important though yeah but they're not
just pricing everything because I I
always say on the masterminds you'll
always have problems your first problem
is I can't get a deal then your problem
is I've got a deal but I ain't got the
money then it's I got the money but I
haven't got a guarantor then it's I've
got it but I'm not getting bookings and
then it's okay I've got it I'm getting
bookings but the guests are driving me
mad and it's and then okay now I've got
systems in Praise now I'm being that
registered how do I do that now it's I'm
paying too much tax I need a good you're
always gonna have problems yeah and it's
it's so important to have people around
you as you say you know people around
you that you can pick the brain off and
say oh you know you've had this
challenge before what can I yeah because
you can figure out yourself and be a
busy fool or you can just find somebody
that's gone before you how did your um
Family feel when you quit your job you
said that you didn't tell them you got
the bank manager on the academy but
whatever when you quit your job they was
really disappointed in me well yeah
really disappointed uh they probably
didn't talk to me for a little while oh
wow I don't live at home with my family
anymore I live with Alfie's family but
when I sort of went round there to tell
them that I'd quit my job I was they was
really disappointed my mum more side
than my dad my dad kind of believed in
me a little bit more but my mom is very
much old-fashioned of you know work in
your job she works in the NHS so that's
just what she knows but I'm just excited
to like prove everyone wrong obviously
you're not going to have everyone on
your side at the beginning well as I say
at first they'll say be careful then
it's well we'll see yeah and then it's
well money isn't everything
and then it's actually can I pick your
brain yeah can I have a coffee with you
you know and that's just part of the
process and then like again your
environment is everything and it gives
you belief as well if you're hanging
around people that are financially free
and it's like okay this is doable but if
you're just on your own trying to be
successful watching YouTube videos where
you in a negative job environment your
friends and family think you're crazy
it's gonna be tough so I think I think
the very first step is just get around
good people another thing as well like
the live training I think the first one
we've done was the rent to rent and then
every time we left like the energy you
leave leaving the course is like this
unmatchable yeah and I thought well go
home and I'm shouting to my mom and dad
talking really loud and sort of like oh
but it's just because the engine I've
been watching you for four days yeah
you get home and you'll be like high
five
with you why are you so happy yeah even
after that enough a week or two goes by
you've been doing a train and then you
start to come down a little bit and then
all of a sudden it's like all right the
next course comes and then you're going
down and then you sort of come to the
course you love and then bang you're up
again right so it's like every time
you're in that environment your energy
is high and then you come away and
you're more ready to do work and you're
just ready to hit the phones message
everything that's interesting yeah I
guess it's probably true you know big
energy is Big Bank if you've got a low
energy and you're coming from a negative
quiet space and you're out trying to get
deals and negotiate and you know secure
things and sell deals because if you've
got high energy yeah you're positive and
you're upbeat and you and your your best
version of yourself I guess it's easier
to get deals yeah what's the uh what's
the strongest reason for you then I mean
what was the the reason that really made
you feel like I wanna I wanna pursue
Financial Freedom time freedom I think
for us is everything we've
since a young age we've both sort of
said like I can't imagine working for
someone my whole life I can't imagine
working that hard to retirement that
that's the only time you've got to then
enjoy you've got no free time we like to
travel we like to be able to do what we
want when we want get what we want when
we want that was definitely a big
driving factor it's the time you there's
not any job in the world where you're
working for someone where you would get
the time Freedom like you can running
your own property business yeah yeah for
sure you only live once yeah yeah you've
got to enjoy it so what were your final
words of advice for people wanting to
get into property maybe they've not got
loads of money they're young but they
really want to get that time Freedom you
guys have got what would you say I'd say
find a mentor who you attract to because
you can watch a lot of people on YouTube
and there's a lot of people out there
but find someone who you who you think
you can trust watch their videos and
then go through with them definitely get
a mentor because I'd say without you you
definitely wouldn't be here for a start
yeah and invest in your education
because six months ago we knew nothing
about property and if we was trying to
do this on our own without a mentor we'd
probably still be trying to learn now
yeah obviously you're learning along the
way but investing in a mentor taking big
big action and and persevering through
kind of the downs and the nose and the
rejections you just gotta see the light
at the end of the tunnel and it will all
be worth it well you guys have done
really well we're super proud of you
Jess and Alfie at Primal Estates yeah
and look forward to seeing your
continued success thank you
[Music]
thank you